Moscow has stepped up a pre-winter campaign
to strike civilian infrastructure in Ukraine
using missiles and drones as NATO members
promise to send Kyiv more air defense
systems. My guest this week on Conflict Zone
from the Berlin Foreign Policy Forum is NATO
Secretary General Jens Stoltenberg. How far
can NATO members increased support for Ukraine
go to help Kyiv repel Putin’s invasion?
“The systems NATO allies and partners have
delivered have already made a huge difference.
This is one of the reasons why Russia has
not been able to gain air superiority,
control over the airspace over Ukraine.”
As Putin issues veiled nuclear threats, how
strong is NATO‘s deterrence today? And how well
is it positioned to confront security threats
of the future, including those posed by China?
Secretary General Stoltenberg,
welcome to Conflict Zone.
Thank you so much for having me, Sarah.
In the past week, Ukrainian cities,
far from the front lines, including
the capital Kyiv, have been waking up
to deadly Russian airstrikes, which appear to
be targeting infrastructure in civilian areas.
What do you think Putin aims
to achieve with these strikes?
I think the aim is to reduce the determination
of the Ukrainian people to stand up against the
brutal Russian invasion of their country. But
I think he will fail, as he has failed in all
the other attempts in trying to take control
over Ukraine since the invasion in February.
And this demonstrates the brutality of the
war. It demonstrates how we see civilian
casualties and now also critical
civilian infrastructure is attacked.
And it just also highlights the importance
of NATO and NATO allies and partners that
we continue to provide support to Ukraine.
And to that end, last week, NATO members
committed to send more air defense systems and
other aid to Ukraine. Do you think the new systems
will be enough to stop the onslaught of Russian
attacks with long-range weapons, including drones?
I think that the systems we are now providing
are making a huge difference. They have already
made a difference in shooting down a lot
of the Russian missiles, drones. But also,
we will make even more difference in the
future because allies are now stepping
up. We have Germany, who has just delivered a
new, very advanced, modern air defense systems.
Right.
And during the NATO defense
ministerial last week, we had several allies — the
United States and also others — announcing more
systems, but also more ammunition and supplies to
existing systems. And this is making a difference.
The Ukrainians are able to shoot down
many of the incoming missiles and drones.
You say that they'll make a difference in
the future. What does the future mean to
you? Because President Zelenskyy says 30% of
Ukraine's power stations have been destroyed
in these attacks. The concern is winter is
quickly approaching. People could struggle
to heat their homes. How quickly can the systems
get there, especially given — and you've admitted
this — there are production shortages in the West.
Well, the systems NATO allies and partners have
delivered have already made a huge difference.
This is one of the reasons why Russia has not
been able to gain air superiority, control over
the airspace over Ukraine. And that has been a
big disadvantage for the Russian troops throughout
the operation. They expected that they were going
to take control of the airspace. They have not
been able to take control of the airspace over
Ukraine. This is, of course, first and foremost
because of the skills, the determination of
the Ukrainian armed forces using the air defense
systems they already had, old the Soviet types of
air defense. What NATO allies have done is that we
have provided ammunition to those old systems, and
then we are also bringing in new systems. And the
latest example is the German system, demonstrating
that Germany is now actually delivering important
capabilities to Ukraine. And they will make then
even more difference in the in the future. Winter
is coming. And that was also the main message from
the defense ministerial. So we need to ramp up
support also everything from winter clothing,
generators, tents, so we can help and ensure that
the Ukrainians can operate throughout the winter.
Let's talk a little bit more about the urgency for
action. And I'd like to turn to the battlefield
now. Ukraine, as we all know, has been recapturing
territory on the front lines in the east and in
the south. But there are some reports, including
today, that troops in the Donbas region have
slowed almost to a halt. Russian reinforcements,
in the meantime, have rushed to the front line,
attempting to break Ukraine's momentum.
How critical do you see this moment right
now? Not in the future. Right now for Ukraine's
counter-offensive as the colder months settle in.
So, wars are, by nature, unpredictable. And
of course, there are still a lot of Russian
forces' capabilities in Ukraine. And they have
what we have seen over the last weeks and days
is actually the most serious escalation of
the conflict since the invasion in February.
Because if you put together their mobilization
and the forces they are now able to send to the
front with their partial — now, with the
illegal annexation of Ukrainian territory
and the dangerous nuclear rhetoric — all of that
represents the biggest escalation since the war.
So, again, we need to just step up our support.
And of course, this support has proven extremely
important because this has enabled the Ukrainians
to first push the Russians out of the area around
Kyiv and then halt the Russian offensive in
Donbas and then launch a counteroffensive
where they have been able to regain, retake a
lot of territory in Donbas and also push against
the Russian forces in the south, in Kherson.
The Ukrainians say they need more tanks in
order to push forward. We're sitting here today,
we're speaking from the Berlin Foreign Policy
Forum. Germany — a NATO member — is facing
criticism for not sending heavier military
equipment to Ukraine, including Leopard
2 battle tanks. From your point of view,
should Germany provide the tanks to Ukraine now?
So Germany has provided and is providing a lot
of essential equipment to Ukraine with advanced
air defense systems and other advanced weapons
and also ammunition and artillery. Other
allies have provided similar types of support,
and other allies have also provided armored
vehicles and also a lot of extremely important
different types of support to Ukraine.
But Mr. Secretary General, I would just
like to underscore the urgency that we have
been hearing and I'd like to mention a quote,
for example, from Latvia's defense minister, and
I'm going to read it out to you now. He says: "If
Germany would give to Ukraine proportionately what
we have given to Ukraine, this war would be over."
Does Germany, and other larger
EU states, need to do more now?
We all need to do more now. And that was the
message from the defense ministers when they
met last week. And we also saw significant new
announcements about more supplies. Then we had
to realize that so far what we have done is to
mostly provide supplies or support to Ukraine
by depleting our existing stocks. At some stage
we cannot continue to do so. So now we need also
to ramp up production. And that was also the
other message from the NATO defense ministers,
was that we now engage directly with the industry
to be able to replenish our existing stocks of
ammunition, of capabilities, so we can, on par,
both uphold our own deterrence and defense,
but also continue to provide support to Ukraine.
I want to talk a little bit more about the ramp-up
of production and the fact that that is a hole
right now. But first, Putin says that he will use,
and I'm quoting here, "all weapons systems
available to defend territory." This is
being seen as a thinly-veiled nuclear threat.
This week, NATO is conducting routine nuclear
drills. Russia's annual exercises are usually
taking place late in October. How high is your
concern right now that the Russian drills could
be used to put nuclear weapons on high alert?
We are very closely monitoring what they are
doing and we are vigilant. And of course,
especially when they now are going
to conduct a nuclear exercise.
Having said that, the risk of any nuclear
attack against Ukraine, the use of nuclear
weapons against Ukraine, is low. But of course,
the potential impact — the consequence — is so
big. So this is a risk we have to take seriously.
And we do so by conveying clearly to Russia that
there will be severe consequences for Russia if
they use a nuclear weapon in Ukraine. And also
reminding Russia of [the fact ] that a nuclear war
cannot be won and must never be fought. And we,
of course, stay vigilant and monitor closely
what they do. So far, we haven't seen any
changes in their nuclear posture and nuclear
readiness. But this is something we're constantly
monitoring and especially when they
now conduct a nuclear exercise.
But given the attack on the Kerch Strait
Bridge in occupied Crimea in early October.
and Ukraine's recent retaking of territory in the
country's south and east, do you think personally
that a humiliated Putin is more
likely to lash out at this time?
I will be careful speculating about the different
risks and the different scenarios. We need to be
prepared for all eventualities. And that's
exactly what we are. And at the same time,
we cannot be intimidated or suffer or accept
blackmailing from Russia, because I think that
this nuclear rhetoric and the threats we have seen
from Russia - the aim is, of course, to coerce us,
to blackmail us, to stop providing support
to Ukraine. But if we do that, then President
Putin will win in Ukraine. And if he wins in
Ukraine, that will send a very dangerous message
to all authoritarian leaders that when
they use military force in a brutal way,
violate international law, they will achieve
their goals. That will make us more vulnerable.
It will make the world more dangerous. And
therefore, yes, there are risks with all
options in this conflict. But I think the risk
of letting President Putin win is much higher
than to continue to support Ukraine as we do.
You and NATO members, you have emphasized and I'm
quoting here, "Russia must understand that nuclear
war can never be won and must never be fought."
Do you have any assurances that that
message is being heard by Putin?
Yes, partly because it has been communicated
so many times from NATO allies, from also the
United States and other NATO allies that possesses
nuclear weapons, and from the whole alliance. And
actually, this is also something that Russia has
subscribed to. So this is a well-known message.
You've warned of severe consequences. Such as?
We will never go into the exact way we will
respond, partly because that will depend so
much on the kind of attack, the circumstances,
the context, but also because we will never give
a potential adversary the privilege of knowing
exactly how we will respond. They know it will
be severe consequences. And we have repeated
that message several times over the last weeks.
But do all 30 NATO allies agree
on what the response would be?
All NATO allies agree on the seriousness
of any use of nuclear weapons. And this
has been clearly conveyed from me and
from also many other NATO allies. Second,
I think we need to distinguish between the use of
weapons of mass destruction or nuclear weapons in
Ukraine and any attack on a NATO ally. An attack
on a NATO ally will, of course, trigger Article 5,
our collective defense clause, and to ensure
that there is no room for miscalculation,
for misunderstanding in Moscow about that, we have
increased our military presence in eastern part of
alliance, increased the readiness of our forces
to make sure that an attack on a NATO ally will,
of course, trigger a response from the
whole alliance. And we do that not to
provoke a conflict, but to prevent the
conflict, to preserve peace. And that's
fundamentally the same as NATO has done for
more than 70 years [as it] faced a nuclear
threat or a challenge from the Soviet Union.
Here's the response from Moscow. Putin's ally,
Dmitry Medvedev, says that he thinks the NATO
military alliance would not risk a nuclear war
and directly enter the Ukraine war, even if Moscow
struck Ukraine with nuclear weapons. Is he right?
He is not right. Because what we have
stated clearly that is that there will
be severe consequences, but we have not
lined out or gone into details what kind of
consequences there will be. And of course,
we have many ways to respond. And and and
that's exactly what we have communicated.
While you warned, though, Moscow of severe
consequences, French President Emmanuel Macron
says that French — a French nuclear response to
Russia using its own atomic arsenal against
Ukraine or the region — is off the table.
That statement wasn't very helpful
for your deterrence, was it?
But we have different ways of reacting. It
doesn't have to be any use of nuclear weapons.
What we have stated again and again is that the
circumstances in which NATO would consider the
use of a nuclear weapon remains very remote, but
that does not take away the possibility of NATO to
respond, and NATO allies to respond, if there is
a use of nuclear weapon by Russia against Ukraine.
And again, if there is any attack against a NATO
ally, we have the whole alliance and Article 5 and
our collective defense clause. And the purpose
of that is to prevent that from happening.
Russia says that western states' support of
Ukraine — you've mentioned what NATO members
are sending to Ukraine — help make them a direct
party to the conflict. With NATO members supplying
the majority of support, isn't it going to be
difficult for members to not be seen as a direct
party? How are you toeing that line going forward?
No, because we are not party to the conflict.
Meaning that we don't have forces on the ground.
We don't participate in the fighting. But what we
do is that we provide support to Ukraine. Ukraine
has the right for self-defense. This is a right
which is enshrined in the UN treaty. Every nation
has the right to defend themselves against a war
of aggression, a brutal attack, as we have seen
against Ukraine. And NATO allies are helping
Ukraine to uphold that right for self-defense.
But that doesn't make us a party to the conflict.
I'd like to ask you about NATO enlargement,
and in particular, Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy announced a bid for fast-track
membership of NATO. He pointed to the examples of
Finland and Sweden. Will you agree to fast-track
NATO's bid [from Ukraine] in the next 12 months?
It's nothing new that Ukraine has the ambition of
joining NATO. NATO's position remains unchanged.
NATO's door is open. We have demonstrated that
over the last years with North Macedonia and
Montenegro, but also with Finland and Sweden. And
of course, we also strongly conveyed the message
that every nation has the right to choose some own
path, including, of course, Ukraine. At the end of
the day, it will be for the 30 NATO allies and
Ukraine to decide on membership. Russia doesn't
have any say in that. Our main focus now is...
Right.
...on ensuring that Ukraine wins the
war and therefore all our focus is on
providing support to Ukraine.
But the question is, do you
personally support NATO — Ukraine's
application for fast-track membership.
I personally stand by the decisions we have made,
which is on saying that NATO's door remains open
and that Ukraine one day will be a member of the
alliance. But the short-term, the priority now,
is on providing support to Ukraine to enable
them to make more gains on the battlefield and
then to ensure that we can end the war in a way
that ensures that Ukraine remains a sovereign,
independent nation in Europe. That's a
precondition for any discussion about membership.
You have, though, and I'd just like to quote you
here, you have supported Finland and Sweden's bid.
You came out and you said "this would
be an historic moment." Why do you dodge
clearly answering whether or not you
support Ukraine in a fast-track bid?
Because I strongly believe that Ukraine is in a
different position than Finland and Sweden are.
Finland and Sweden are long-term partners of NATO.
We have consensus in the alliance on inviting them
to become members. We made that decision at
the summit in Madrid in May. What we see in
Ukraine is a war going on and the top priority is
therefore to provide military support to Ukraine,
as we do as NATO's allies and partners. And
this military support is unprecedented. And
it's really helped the Ukrainians to now
make gains on the battlefield. Of course,
the victories on the battlefield is something
that belongs to the brave Ukrainian soldiers.
But without the support from NATO allies, they
would have not been able to make these gains
and to push the Russian invading forces
back, as I've seen over the last weeks.
If we look back in 2008, NATO pledged that Ukraine
would eventually become an alliance member.
Ukraine, of course, has this on paper. Did NATO
give false hopes to Ukraine all those years ago?
No, this is still the ambition of the alliance.
But the focus has been since 2008 on reforms,
on capacity building, on supporting Ukraine in
moving towards NATO membership. As I also know
that EU members have been working with Ukraine,
moving towards EU membership, but of course since
2014 we have been in a situation where Russia
has annexed Crimea and controlled the eastern
part of Donbas. So the main focus has then been
to provide military support to Ukraine and NATO
allies — like especially the United States, the
United Kingdom, Canada —have trained and equipped
the Ukrainian forces not since February,
but since 2014. And that has ensured that
Ukrainian armed forces are much bigger, much
better trained, much better led, much better
equipped now than in 2014. And this is making a
huge difference on the battlefield as we speak.
Let's turn briefly to your strategic concept
and to future threats. At the Chinese Communist
Party Congress, President Xi Jinping said
that China would use, and I'm quoting here,
"all necessary measures to secure Taiwan."
Is the next conflict for NATO with China?
Well, Taiwan is not a NATO member, so our
collective defense clause doesn't apply for
Taiwan. But what we see is...
But Mr. Secretary General,
how would NATO respond, if China were to
invade Taiwan? How would NATO's respond?
I'm not going to outline exactly how NATO
will respond. What we have stated clearly,
and that's for the first time in our strategic
concept, is that the rise of China matters
to our security. And it is a challenge for our
values, for our interests, and for our security.
And that is because China is now investing
heavily in new modern military capabilities,
also long-range missiles, nuclear weapons. We
see how they don't share our values in the way
they crack down on democratic voices, forces
in Hong Kong, the minorities they abuse, and
also how they coerce countries in the region. So
all of this makes it important for us to address
the rise of China, not by isolating China. China
is important also to engage with, and therefore,
we are both addressing the security challenges,
but also the need to engage with China as we do.
And I met recently with the Chinese foreign
minister and that was my main message to him.
The head of the British cyber intelligence
agency, he put it this way. He describes
the security threat posed by Russia as affecting
the weather, while China's affects the climate.
What do you think there is to be learned
from allies' support of Ukraine against
the Russian invasion, should China move
to invade or to illegally annex territory?
That's always unacceptable that one country tried
to grab land from another country. And that's the
reason why we have reacted so strongly
against the Russian invasion of Ukraine,
because this is the biggest land grab since the
Second World War, world war in Europe. And also
why we conveyed to China that, of course, they
should be able to at least condemn the illegal
war of Russia against Ukraine. And also one of
the reasons why we support Ukraine is to send
a message to all other authoritarian leaders
that we don't accept this kind of behavior.
I'd like to also ask you, you said last week that
when we look at the situation in Ukraine, that
allies have had to dip into their
own arsenals in order to send
supplies there. Were NATO members too complacent?
Because if you look just at the first half of
the year, only nine members were spending 2%
of GDP or more on defense. Now, it seems to be a
bit of a scramble in order to get stockpiles and
increase production capacities. And it's coming
amid hard economic times. Can it stay a priority?
I have, we have pushed for more defense
investments across the alliance for many years,
and of course we would like to see even
more defense spending. Having said that,
what we have seen since 2014 is the biggest
reinforcement of NATO's collective defense
since the end of the Cold War. Until 2014, NATO
allies were cutting defense spending. Since 2014,
all NATO allies have increased defense spending
with hundreds of billions of extra US dollars,
and we have increased the readiness of
forces. For the first time in history we
have battlegroups in the eastern part of the
alliance and all of this were triggered by the
Russian annexation of Crimea and the control over
eastern Donbas. So we were actually prepared when
the invasion happened in February. We actually
warned against it since last fall, shared
intelligence depicting exactly the Russian plans
to invade Ukraine. And on the day of the invasion,
we activated our defense plans and further
increased our military presence in the east.
Briefly, before we go, Secretary General, must
Putin go for there to be a resolution in Ukraine?
Yes or no?
Again, I will not... But you will not force me to
give a yes or no answer to that. What we will do
is that we will respond to the actions of Russia,
regardless of who is in charge there. And we will
continue to call on them to end this war. It was
President Putin that started this war, and it's
President Putin who could end this war tomorrow
by withdrawing his forces. We have to remember
that if President Putin and Russia stops fighting,
there will be peace. If President
Zelenskyy and Ukraine stops fighting,
Ukraine will cease to exist as an independent
nation. And we don't want that to happen. That's
exactly why we provide support to Ukraine.
NATO's secretary general, Jens Stoltenberg.
Thank you very much for joining us on
Conflict Zone. Thank you for your time.